oh so everything is bad wouldn't it be
crazy if I knew what I was doing by now
no no you know your life is different
now we're making a food you already know
this and I've said this a million times
it's Halloween season Plus recently I
found in a random drawer in my kitchen a
like sushi rolling kit that I think my
brother got me years ago shut up - Tim
and I got kind of excited about it so I
actually made sushi the other day and I
really wanted to make a video making
sushi for you but I didn't know exactly
what to do that might make it more
interesting than just making sushi so I
came up with an idea to make it holiday
sushi - sushi the idea of making sushi
is really scary even though when you do
it you realize it's actually pretty easy
I'm basically just gonna try and dye
sushi rice orange and then fill the
sushi with avocado so that it's the
black seaweed roll with orange rice and
green avocado and it looks like a
pumpkin and maybe somehow it is relevant
to this time of year in which this video
is being made it's a stretch I also
don't know if you can actually die sushi
rice or rice in general I haven't looked
it up at all so let's mix boobie sushi
here's the ingredients you'll need so
she writes avocado food coloring seaweed
and something to roll sushi in according
to the instructions on the sushi rice
you're supposed to rinse your sushi rice
until it runs clear have a second camera
setup because I care one cup of sushi
rice Oh perfect it's all perfect oh my
god two angles oh my god two angles just
got impro raised until it runs clear
yeah seems like enough this camera angle
totally worth it how do I make this
camera angle more person we need one and
a half cups of water 1 cup half a cup
now you're supposed to soak your sushi
rice for like 30 minutes before you cook
it
so that's the end of this bit see you in
a bit wow that's not the many things
that happened while our rice is cooked
all our rice was cooking I wouldn't
run then took a shower redid my makeup
and somehow found this janitor possibly
jumpsuit in my house that I have no idea
where it came from and put it on my body
with no other questions asked but if you
want to know how I cook my rice here we
took our soaked rice and put it in a
saucepan and brought to a boil and then
reduce the heat to a low simmer let it
cook for 20 minutes with a tight-fitting
lid on then we removed from the heat and
let it steam for 10 minutes and that's
what we're at now and this is where
things get fun or dumb or bad I've never
died raised before but I think this
might be the time to do I have no have
dye that's supposed to be for cake icing
but rice and cake icing are kind of the
same do we have orange or red to make
our orange seems to be the most
complicated one of the colors to me okay
perfect
that seems good oh no boom wow I should
have maybe added this in at an earlier
Wow
oh no this is very autumnal actually
this does look orange I am really
impressed with my artistic skills and
also my ability to slightly follow
directions Wow
you can die right so spoopy we're gonna
let this cool down for a little bit
before we make spooky sushi out of it
look I look like I killed someone very
spoopy okay we're back but their oranges
right avocados yeah seaweed wraps like I
said I made this one time before which
makes me an expert so I don't need to
look up instructions on how to roll
sushi anymore look for a sushi rolling
kit like I said my brother got me this
one who knows how long ago because I
care about the gifts that my family
gives me comes with a little tray a rice
spoon so you can spoon it out and it
won't stick hopefully a box with the
this part I don't understand and then
this is the most important apparatus
this is the sushi rolling mat the first
time I rolled sushi because there's
little like skewers here I got rice
stuck in between them and the nice
line that someone said if you put saran
wrap over your sushi rolling mat you can
save on that sort of trouble that's with
some saran wrap on this no also you're
supposed to have a bowl of water near
you so that you can dip your fingers
into the water so it doesn't stick to
the rice it's so sticky to begin with
we're gonna take some rice and we're
basically just gonna put a full layer of
orange Halloween rice all over working
perfectly perfectly you guys aren't
gonna see me clean up this thing
afterwards forget the saran wrap this is
definitely the right way to do all of
this no it's not I'm supposed to put the
seaweed down first
mother it's okay we can salvage just
watch this go back to your friends we
have a clean dish sushi rolling board
we're gonna take our seaweed and put it
down then put our sushi rice on top
because we're not idiot leave a little
bit of an edge around the seaweed hey we
did it now we're gonna cut up some
avocados and place them in what's this
what your what's your what's your
favorite Halloween costume that you've
ever been in the whole time that you've
done Halloween costume great love it
maybe we just do half an avocado I'm
stressed because I think this might be
good now we roll our sushi oh I put it
on the OH
it's supposed to roll this way okay
let's move that this is easier to move
we did it perfect from the get-go there
we go we're gonna roll sushi ready super
easy me roll and then you're supposed to
push it it and then we're all keep
rolling and tightening and then we undo
it oh my god we got a sushi roll we got
an extra piece of avocado on the side
now we got to cut the sushi this kit
also came with a sushi knife which I in
one-time making sushi have already
ruined sushi knife just start cutting
from the middle oh my god and half again
half again oh my god oh my god we might
do this with the amazing Wow so spoopy
good yeah we did it
focus on those and not the gross
everywhere wait Walker you want to taste
test six this is our halloween duo
costume guess what we are
there's no right answer these are these
were the weird thing about this I think
is gonna be that the orange rice looks
like it should have a different taste
than it will have it's just gonna be
really rough yeah sure cheers
congratulations
boopy boopy Georgia is tough really got
you did it makes poopy sushi don't fish
I'm proud of her you are in the comments
bye there you go I made let me know if
you guys make this at home tag me in and
these photos on Instagram or Twitter if
you decide to make this subscribe to
this YouTube channel I make videos
Monday Wednesday and Friday
sometimes click that Bell notification
so that you no inconsistency is the only
thing I'm consistent at Matt I don't
know you don't want to try it no I do
want try just doing it look weird cuz I
mean I mean just a towel cuz my closer
game washed I have any clothes yeah I
look normal and you look weird yeah